(crowd cheering)
- Morning.
(crowd cheers)
It's early.
Wait, I only have 20 minute...
oh there we go,
okay I got scared.
Good morning,
super excited to be here.
Really, really fun to be here.
So what do I want to talk about?
Look I think there's a
lot of things going on
and I feel an enormous
kinship to this audience.
I think through my career
over the last 10 years,
I've spent a lot of time
interacting, engaging with,
I have a lot of
friends in this industry,
and I think it's
been really interesting
for me to watch this space
evolve over the last decade.
I think I spoke at this
event maybe eight years ago,
or something of that nature
and back then it was like,
hey, there's technology
and there's these things like
Google AdWords and Twitter,
and things of that nature.
And clearly we've evolved in
a very big way from there.
You know I think what
I want to really talk
about today is a
couple of core things.
A, attention.
I think the one thing that
binds everybody in this room,
depending on how much
business they're doing,
what market they are in,
how long they've been
in the industry, how they
roll, hold on real quick,
is that a Jets Jersey?
I love you.
(crowd laughs and cheers)
The one thing that
100% binds all of you
is that before you tell me
how great this house is,
or this property is,
or how great you are,
we are all battling in
this room for attention.
And attention is fickle,
and attention moves.
And that is basically
been my career.
My career has been
predicated on what I call,
day trading attention.
I wanna know where people
are, and I wanna figure out
how to story tell
to them in that medium,
and if that meant billboards,
'cause people drove
and continue to, great.
If that means direct mail,
because people were going
through their mail very
carefully and aggressively,
in the 60s, 70s,
80s, 90s, great.
And then for me,
as some of you know,
that became the internet
itself, and so I launched
an e-commerce website in
the wine business in 1997
long before people believed
that people would buy wine
through the internet.
I think for, how many
people here by show of hands
have made an
Instagram Story already?
Raise your hands, so for
about 30 or 40 of you,
you know that attention
can shift in minutes.
48 hours ago, 72 hours ago,
there is no Instagram Stories,
people are trying to figure
out their Snapchat strategies.
I see a lot of Snapchat
shirts in the crowd,
and so these were things,
Snapchat or Instagram Stories
is not something that
I would have even been able
to reference at
this conference a year ago
with any seriousness.
Snapchat's something
I've been paying attention to.
And so that's basically
the punchline.
The punchline is,
what are you doing
in a 2017 environment
that's actually gonna
help you sell more homes,
bring more awareness, build
your business, build your brand,
what are those strategies,
what are those implications?
Here's what I want to establish
right away, this morning,
which is A:
we are living through the single
biggest communication shift
that we've lived through
since the printing press.
The first thing you have to
really wrap your head around
in this room, this
morning is how substantial
the culture shift really is.
I think the biggest thing
that I'm fascinated by,
is that every single person in
this room, including myself,
is grossly underestimating
how big of a shift this is.
If you were just sitting
in my shoes right now,
you would realize there's
about 90 people right now
holding up a cell phone
recording this talk.
You have to understand
how interesting that is,
because 10 years ago we didn't
even have smart phones, right.
We were definitely not
recording content at scale.
At scale!
We are producing
content at a level
we've never seen before,
and so what that means
to everybody in this room is
something very interesting.
Here's what it means.
We have a massive
supply and demand issue.
You're trying to
get somebody's attention
for what you're
trying to sell them,
the problem is that end
user is getting pounded
with 500, 10,000 times
the amount of content
that they did just 10 years ago.
And so how are you going to
break through that environment?
Because it's not just if they're
in the market to buy a new home,
it's every product and
service that they are trying
to achieve in their lives.
And to me, that is a
fascinating, fascinating
supply and demand issue
that every single person
in this room is dealing with.
So how do you break through?
What do you do?
I think what you first
have to do is recognize
that attention is driving
very, very quickly.
I think the biggest thing
that concerns me this morning,
more than anything is,
have you become complacent
or romantic about what's
working for your business now?
The biggest thing that
I'm fascinated by is
when something
works for somebody,
do they try to milk it forever
and hope nothing changes.
A lot of you know, a lot
of you in this room know
that Twitter was
my coming out party
in the digital world.
I invested in it,
I became big on it, I amassed
a million followers on it,
it is devastating to me
that Twitter does not hold
the attention that it once
did six or seven years ago.
I spent every single
hour between 7:00 p.m.
and two in the
morning from 2007 to 2011
in my life
to amass an audience on Twitter,
but in 2011 when
I started noticing
that even though
I had 800,000 followers
and I was posting something,
that I was not getting
the same results that I was
when I had 50,000 followers,
that became the moment that I,
instead of what most people do,
which is desperately
try to hold on,
put my head in the sand or
what a lot of people's strategy
is in this this
room on digital shifts,
which is (holds breath) hope,
fuckin' hope,
that everything's gonna be okay.
What I started doing in
2011 was I started investing
a lot more time and energy
in figuring out Instagram,
in 2012 and '13,
in figuring out Snapchat.
I spent a lot of time on
things that didn't work out,
SocialCam became something
I spent a lot of time in in 2012.
Vine became something
I spent a lot of time in 2014.
Pinterest is something
I spent a lot of time
in 2012, 13, 14, right?
Tumblr was something
I spent a lot of time on.
So they're not all wins,
but the biggest thing
that I could leave
you with in this room,
and again there's been a
dramatic knowledge gain
in this collective room, even
getting ready for this talk,
looking at your content,
your hashtags, your tweets,
it's just such
a higher understanding.
There's still some
tried and true things
that are not being executed.
Last night I stayed in my
bed when I got here late
and just went through
a lot of your accounts
that were using the
hashtag or mentioning them.
I'm just like what's
the state of the union,
of the people in the room,
how are they rolling?
Couple things, one,
unfortunately,
the last two books before
the #AskGaryVee book,
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
and The Thank You Economy are
both still very
underutilized by the market.
People continue
to put out content
that is in high percentage
in their best interest
and not in the
value of the end user.
I am still baffled by why
the real estate industry
on a individual broker
level does not realize
that they need to become the
digital mayor of their town.
And what I mean by that is,
the number one blueprint
that fundamentally, look,
you're gonna be
here the whole time
and you're gonna
get a lot of good content
from a lot of people.
You're gonna here a
couple of nuggets from me,
a lot of them move the
needle a little bit.
A lot of them move the
needle a little bit,
you might sell two more
homes, four more homes.
To fundamentally
change your business
where you go from
where you are now
to five, 10, 20X
the revenue and volume,
you have to
make dramatic changes.
And that dramatic
change sits in the form,
and here it is, here it is,
and by the way 99% of you
are not gonna do anything
about what I'm about to say,
(crowd laughs)
I'm being very honest with you
because the punchline
here is, it's hard work.
And the reality is,
that a lot of people
are just not
willing to put in the work.
I mean that's just the
fundamental reality.
As a matter of fact,
I always think
that digital excites people
because they think its scalable.
They think that all of a
sudden the computer's going
to do the fuckin'
work for them, right?
The number one shift that
everybody has to do in this room
is understand the
following statement,
and understand it cold,
not just shake your head
when you hear the words
coming out of my mouth.
The quicker you
understand in this room
that you are a media company-
comma-real estate agent,
real estate software provider,
whatever you may be,
I know that I am a media
company-comma-an agency CEO,
a wine retailer.
Once you make that shift
everything changes.
For example, when you
make that mental shift,
the content that you put
out on Facebook and Twitter
and Pinterest and
Instagram and Snapchat,
fundamentally changes.
Right now, what many
of you do for a living,
you're forced to be in
the right hook business.
What the hell are you gonna
put out, content-wise, right?
When you decide to become
the digital mayor of your town,
everything
fundamentally changes.
If you decide that you,
not the local newspaper,
is going to be the
provider of the content
of the best restaurants,
reviewing the school system,
and every other nook and cranny,
in the two, four, six, and
eight towns that you live in,
you fundamentally start
bringing value to end users
that are intrigued or interested
into moving into your town.
I do not believe that
most people sitting
here this morning think
that they're gonna be the
editor in chief of a newspaper.
But that is absolutely how
I view every single one of you.
That you have the potential
to be that content producer.
You're filming now; you could
be filming a lot of things
that actually bring value to
the person that's debating
to go from the city to your
suburbs, they are looking
for that information,
why can't you,
you Sally, you fucking Frank,
you Frank,
(audience laughs)
why can't you--
why can't you be the
person that interviews
the principal of
all the schools?
Why can't you be the
person that writes a review
of every dish of every
restaurant in your town?
Why can you not be that person?
That is my belief that is
the wide open white space,
for every person in this room
that changed their business,
because you then become
synonymous with the town.
You become the media entity.
You become the person that
fundamentally has the attention
and what comes out of that,
and this is very
important to understand,
is your ability then to market
yourself at a greater sense
because the
content is dramatically,
dramatically more viral
in the number one platform that
everybody should be spending
all their time on,
which is Facebook.
In a world where everybody's
very excited about all
the new things, as am I,
I live and breathe for it,
even besides the
Snapchats of the world,
I'm paying attention to
Anchor, and Musical.ly,
and Peach, and After School,
and there's plenty of things
bubbling up that I'm curious,
in two to three years
will matter to you,
and you can sell from,
even in that world,
we are sitting
in a very interesting time.
One of the things that
I thought was very fascinating
when I digged a little deep
into a lot of the comments,
I went back a little bit,
I was curious what you guys said
back in November,
December, and January,
about the Facebook feed, right?
What did this collective
group think about that?
And, much to what I thought,
people were very upset
and complaining, right?
People were upset that
six months ago, a year,
you lost a lot of your
organic reach on Facebook,
it wasn't as good anymore.
Zucks fucked you, right?
(audience laughs)
What I found fascinating
about that was that in lieu
of that feed,
organic growth going away,
what grew was one of the
greatest ad
products of all time.
If you're sitting in
this room this morning,
you have a real career,
a real business.
The fact that most of the people
in this room do not deploy
at least a thousand
dollars a month
into a Facebook environment
to drive their business
is borderline laughable
and in reality
just down right stupid.
Let me explain why.
By show of hands, how
many people in this room,
when they watch
television now
watch it on their time,
not when the actual thing
airs, but between DVR,
Netflix, HBOGo,
besides live sports,
and I know it's early
and some of you are lazy,
but raise your hands 'cause
it's important for everybody,
how many people watch TV now
on their time, raise your hand.
Good, everybody.
(laughter)
How many people in this
room, when given the chance
fast-forward every
single commercial?
My friends, I live in a
world now, VaynerMedia,
I run a 650 person
digital agency,
it's a hundred million
dollar revenue business,
Toyota, Unilever,
Under Armour, USA networks,
biggest brands in the
world, Dove, the whole nine,
they spend 90 billion
dollars, collectively,
making videos and distributing
them to sell you stuff.
Right?
I live in a world where
I day trade attention.
Every person in this room,
and I think we can agree,
this is not a 15 year
old girl crowd, right?
Every person in this room
just raised their hand
that they do not watch
commercials at all costs.
And even if, even if, even if,
the brand is lucky enough
to get the commercial
in front of you,
because you dropped your
remote control off your bed,
(audience laughter)
even if that happens,
every person here,
the second that
commercial runs, grabs this.
And you check on your business,
you tweet about
what LeBron just did,
you definitely don't
give the attention
to the commercial.
Let me explain why this
matters to this room so much.
How many people
here in their career
did Google AdWords at some
point, raise your hands.
Great, very good.
How many people here did
Google AdWords back in
2001, '2, and '3,
when I was doing them,
just raise your hands.
Uh-huh.
For the 20 of you, you
remember what I remember,
which was it was a great
fucking deal, right?
When I bought the word 'wine,'
the day Google AdWords came out,
for five cents a click, before
Google raised the minimum,
I owned it for nine and a
half months before anybody
even bid me up, because
nobody knew it existed.
My career's been about
day-trading attention.
I grew my dad's
liqour store from a three
to a 60 million dollar
business in five years
because I launched
a website when
nobody thought
websites were important.
How many people here
have done email marketing
in their career,
raise your hand.
You're gonna love this one.
In 1997, I had 150,000 to
200,000 person email newsletter
that had 91% open rates.
(audience groans, laughter)
Yeah.
Not because I was a hero,
oh by the way,
forget about that,
55% click to add to cart
within the email.
Not because I was a
hero or I was so smart
or I wrote such great copy,
it's because nobody was
email marketing in 1997.
Who here had email in '97,
'98, '99, raise your hands.
Do you remember, for the
youngsters in this room,
we read every fucking
word of every email.
(enthusiastic laughter)
We treated email
like it was regular mail.
Like, very carefully, like
'dear John,' yes, good.
All of it.
That same email
newsletter today,
even after ten years of money
and strategy and all this,
is at 33% open rates,
and that's remarkable,
and that's because we've
consciously put a lot of effort
towards it, so that
has been my career.
What I knew would happen
on Google AdWords
is about to happen
in social media.
And my friends,
let's get this straight
in this room right now,
there is no social media.
Social media is a slang term
for the current
state of the internet.
There is no social media,
we called it Web 2.0
for all the OG's in this room,
right?
There is no social media,
social media is a term we use
to talk about Facebook and
Instagram and Snapchat,
and we even throw
LinkedIn and YouTube,
we even throw utilities
and content platforms
into social media,
social media--
you mean the thing that we
spend 51% of our time on
on this device, and if
you sit in this room,
in late 2016 and
you do not understand
that this is the remote
control of our lives,
how many people here,
in every 24 hour window,
are always within arm's
reach of their phone?
(audience chatters in agreement)
I would literally rather
somebody stab me
in the streets of New York and
steal my wallet than
lose my fucking phone.
(laughter, scattered applause)
Attention.
For example, I today,
for all my businesses,
all my 150+ investments,
Wine Library, VaynerMedia,
my personal brand, I don't
even think about the internet
at all in any other platform
than my mobile device.
As a matter of fact,
I just got my design team
at Vaynermedia together
last week and I told them
I wanna redesign
Vaynermedia's website
and in the next month
or so you will go to
Vaynermedia.com and
if you go on it,
in a laptop environment,
it will actually go to a page,
Vaynermedia.com, that
will say the following,
it will look broken,
and it will say to you:
Hey jerk, it's 2017.
Go get your fucking phone.
(laughter)
It will actually not
work on a laptop.
Here's why this is important.
I am extremely
curious what your websites,
how your marketing,
looks in a mobile world.
Many people here have been
very smart about their
landing page optimization,
about their marketing material,
about their videos that
they put on their website,
and a lot of them don't even
work in this environment.
And very quickly,
within 24 months,
what is this, the 20th,
at the 22nd anniversary
of fucking Inman Connect,
the entire end consumer that
you're trying to sell to
will only be living
in this environment.
So if you have any call to
action from this talk today,
please, go home and adjust
your web and social presence
only into a mobile-first
environment,
because there will
be nothing else.
And a lot of you are converting
great leads and other things
through a desktop world,
you've gotta make that same
commitment to understand
what's happening in here,
because this is the punchline,
this is how you will sell.
I've got a friend who,
in the last four months,
has sold four homes
through Facebook Live
at his open home listings from
people that didn't show up
to the open house, it was
just him walking around
with his Facebook Live and
he has a very small group
of like 50 people watching
those Facebook Lives,
but three of his four
transactions were someone
of those 50 sharing it into
the network of their friends,
and then their friends
becoming aware of it.
Literally, I mean this is
what you do for a living,
literally, selling homes
through Facebook Live
because he's,
and think about it,
you guys do open
houses all the time,
I assume some of those
aren't well attended,
sometimes there
is some down time,
multiple times you have
multiple people in the home
that can, one of them,
can hold the phone.
There's real
transactional value going on
in this environment
and I'm just thirsty,
thirsty for people to understand
how big of a deal it is,
because of this
attention arbitrage,
there is so much opportunity.
For example, best practices,
I wanna get very detailed
here today,
to be honest with you.
Instagram: how many
people are using Instagram
for their business,
raise your hand.
If you're posting content on
Instagram for your business,
A, anybody who's not is
making a massive mistake,
because the attention
of 28 to 65 on Instagram
is stunning, deep, and
when you think about
the decision maker
in home transactions,
female gateway drug
to those transactions,
there's enormous attention.
As a matter of fact,
one of the most interesting
data points on
Instagram right now is
the fastest-growing demo
of selfies on Instagram
are 40- to 50-year-old females.
Literally cougar selfies.
(loud audience laughter)
Literally.
- [Audience Member] Meow.
Listen, I love it.
Swiping through it.
I'm enjoying it.
However, one of the
things I did last night
was I went to four of yours,
and that four is a very small
sample group, but I went
to four of your Instagram
accounts and
looked at the content.
Many of you posting content,
rooms, homes, information.
Mixing it up, I'm fine
with the jabbing
and the right hooking,
but when I look at the posts,
of the four people,
only one of them
used a hashtag
and they used one.
So, just to get to details,
A, I would take it
far more seriously,
and I would produce a lot
more content on Instagram.
B, when you post on
Instagram, for so many of you,
you do not have
a large audience.
For so many of you,
there's not a lot of people
following you and
so for so many of you,
I highly, highly
recommend using 10, 15,
25 hashtags because if
you're sitting here today
and you wanna start your
Instagram, you know, journey,
the number one
way to get discovered
is through tactical
hashtag evolution.
So please go into that world,
understand which hashtags
have a lot of results,
don't have a lot of results,
where you can pop out,
whether it's the
name of your towns,
by adding the word house,
or things of that nature.
So much business opportunity
in that environment.
Let's talk about Facebook
again one more time.
Gonna go back to it
because it's super important.
One of the things that
I'm stunned by is how
unbelievably strong the
ad product really is.
One of the things that,
how many people here
have run Facebook ads
for their business?
Raise your hand.
Fantastic.
So we are deep in here.
Couple things.
One of the things that
I have been fascinated by
is Facebook video content
and how it drives down
the cost of conversion on
your non-video content.
So I'm giving you a very
detailed execution here,
but because so many of
you raised your hand,
I'm gonna go there.
One of the things that is
wide open in your space
right now is the
following execution.
This is kind of how
I would pattern it.
And I know I'm going
way more detailed
in this talk than ra-ra,
you can do it,
and I think that's
the right tone.
Here's where we're going.
Open house or
you're gonna list it,
video content, Facebook Live.
Obviously, you have to get
permission from the seller,
you know, you guys
figure all that part out.
First Facebook Live
does that content.
It's very raw, you're
dropping the phone,
you're walking up the
stairs, but when it's done,
it saves and it posts.
You then go into that content
and you edit that video.
Take out parts of that video.
30 seconds here, 60 seconds
there, 30 seconds here.
Now again, some of you
are single practitioners.
Others have people in their
company that can help them.
For the people, how many people
here, if they're gonna do,
bless you, how many people here,
if you're gonna do Facebook
advertising or video creation,
it's gonna be on your head,
you don't have the
overhead or infrastructure
to have somebody else
do it, raise your hands?
Great, so that's a lot of you.
Here's a really important part.
For a lot of you,
for a lot of you,
you're gonna go into
excuse mode right now.
I don't have the time.
I didn't grow up with this.
I love it when people
come up to me like,
"Gary, this technology,
I know it's important,
"but you gotta bear with me,
I didn't grow up with this."
And I'm always like,
"That's fine, Stan.
"But you didn't grow up driving
"and you figured
it the fuck out."
(audience laughter)
The fact that you didn't grow
up with this is not an excuse.
(chuckles) Love that.
So, for a lot of you that
just raised your hand,
there's a lot of things here.
How do you edit
a Facebook video?
How do you post this, how do
you even place a Facebook ad?
Not all of you have done it.
It's really simple.
I know a lot of you have
pads in front of you,
they gave 'em
to you this morning.
I'm gonna give you a website
that will help you tremendously
through this journey if
you wanna write it down.
It's spelled G
O
G
L
E
dot com.
It's called Google.
Every single person here,
basically,
I've been thinking about this
weird format of a keynote,
which is I come out, I say
like the seven or eight things
that I think matter right
now, Facebook video,
you know,
Instagram hashtag culture,
couple of other things,
and then I basically say,
and now go to Google and spend
10 hours on
Google and/or YouTube.
For example,
Google wouldn't work for me,
'cause I'm very bad at reading,
I don't consume
information that way,
so then I would just go
to YouTube and watch the,
you know YouTube by the way is
the second-biggest search
engine in the world.
And so for a lot of you
that are more visual,
if you wanna figure
out how to use Snapchat
or how to use a 360 camera,
which would be a very good idea
for a lot of you here that are
listing that kind of content.
Thank you, man.
The 360 camera dude is here.
(audience laughter)
Um.
- [Audience Member] And here!
- And here, sorry, I got, oh!
And right there!
Respect.
Nerd it up, baby.
I love it.
(audience laughter)
I'm stunned by the
following statement that
I think rings very
true in this room.
How many people, you know
what, I'll ask this question
and it'll make it a lot better
before I make the statement.
How many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years,
and I don't mean you're
gonna crush it and retire.
(laughter)
(chuckles) I mean you're
old and you're finished.
(loud audience laughter)
So, raise you're hand
if you're retiring.
Too young, too young, too young.
You're a little bit older, dude.
I see you in the back.
(laughter)
So for the four
of you that are retiring
in the next 10 years, respect.
You can take a lot of what
I'm saying with a grain of salt.
I do think you
might be able to hold on
for dear life and
hold your breath, right?
For the rest of you, I need
to remind you something.
11 years ago, nothing that we
talk about in society existed.
Not Netflix, not YouTube,
not smartphones, not Facebook.
Zero.
I hope you understand
that the biggest point
of my talk this morning
is not go use that hashtag
or go make YouTube videos,
it's that if you are
not digitally native,
you will die.
And what I mean by that
is not that you will die
that, like, you'll go
directly out of business.
It's just, the people that are
are gonna take your business.
And by the way, you know
what I'm most worried about?
Good markets.
A good year this year.
Success.
That is my enemy.
That is my enemy,
because you become complacive.
It's tried and true,
this works for me,
why the heck do I need to
figure out Facebook video?
Why do I have to
figure out Snapchat?
I'm good now,
I'm the guy in my town,
I'm the 20-year-old
lady that has dominated
Rochester, New York, fuck Gary.
Right?
Like, you know, like,
I don't need this.
I understand.
The problem is, and
let's get really humble
together real quick,
way bigger businesses than you
have been put out of business
because of technology shifts.
Borders was a bigger
business than yours.
Right?
When I invested in
Uber five years ago,
I called my dad's
Russian friends in L.A.
And, you know, how many
people in the L.A. market?
- [A Few Audience Members] Woo!
- Great, awesome (chuckles).
So, a lot of you know a lot
of the black car service
guys and gals over
the last 20 years
came from Eastern Europe,
Soviet Union.
That's where a lot
of my dad's homies came
when we emigrated from Russia.
These are guy,
think about this narrative.
These are my dad's best friends
now in their 50s and 60s.
They came to this
country in '78, '79.
They were dead broke.
They lived in studio apartments.
They drove taxi cabs for
two, three bucks an hour.
Hustled their way, worked every
hour, no Saturday and Sunday
for 20 years, built up a
business, didn't buy anything,
saved all their money,
eventually bought their own car,
eventually had four or five
guys or girls underneath them,
built a business,
had the American dream,
finally got into
their 50s and 60s,
worked every goddamn
minute to get there,
and now were gonna kind of,
like, enjoy it a little bit.
And then Uber came along.
And so I called
Marik and Vladimir
and these guys and said, "Hey."
Vladimir, I know.
And said, "Vlad, I've got
good news and bad news.
"Good news is you've
done well and America's
"the greatest
country in the world.
"Bad news is you
might be in trouble."
And literally, the
three of them, verbatim,
were all like, "That's nice,
boy chick, we'll be okay.
"So, what you're telling me
is they're gonna take a phone
"and hit a button and
the car is gonna come?
"Very good, very good,
I'll talk to you later."
(laughter)
- The funny part is
these are very close
friends of my family.
That's a funny story
and I say it funny.
Here's what's not funny:
every one of those
three guys' businesses
have been slaughtered.
Absolutely slaughtered.
All of their businesses now,
that they're trying to sell,
are literally worth
15 cents on the dollar
of what it was worth
just four years ago.
Their revenues have been
cut from high six figures
to low six figures
even five figures.
They're basically
out of business.
Nobody here is
super excited to go run
and buy an independent
black car service business,
and so the one
thing that I implore
all of you to understand
is in a world where the internet
came along only
twenty years ago...
There's a lot of
youngsters in this room,
so pay very close attention,
especially if you wanna be
in business in 20 years.
Only 20 years ago,
Windows 95 came out
and finally got some
of us on the internet.
Okay?
We're talkin' bout a
very recent phenomenon.
I am very confident that a lot
of my venture capital
friends are gonna lose
a lot of money betting on
virtual reality right now
because it's too early,
but I'm equally as
confident that in 20 years,
we're gonna be deeply
playing in a VR world.
A VR world that is gonna
actually do to the internet,
what the internet
did to real life.
Everything will reset
because the only
thing that matters
to this room is the attention
and if that attention means
we put on contact lenses
and never take them
out and live in a world
that is virtual
alongside with physical,
I think more and
more people here
don't think that
is the most insane thing
they've ever heard.
I think more and
more people here,
especially if they're
45, 50, 60, 70,
remember how they judged
the fad of the internet
and won't do the
same thing with VR.
I think a lot of people
here didn't expect people
randomly running
through their backyard
looking for virtual Pikachus.
(audience laughing)
And so, I just really want
you to understand something.
I basically look
at this like a race.
I think all of you
are about to run
a very long marathon in business
and the reason I want
you to be on Snapchat
is not because
I necessarily fully, 1,000%
believe that Snapchat's
gonna change your business.
It's that I need you to
understand how Snapchat works
because that's like
gonna on a treadmill
and getting prepared
for the marathon.
Nobody here,
without training for it,
ya just gonna wake up tomorrow
and run the New York
marathon successfully.
If you are not acting
digitally every single day,
if you are not understanding
that all the action,
all the opportunity
is in the people
that draw lines in the sand
and say they're not gonna do.
How bout this?
Let's be very honest here
and this is very important.
I want everybody to see this.
How many people in this room,
in the last two or three years,
said that they would
never go on Snapchat?
It was stupid and now
have Snapchat accounts?
Raise your hand.
Raise it.
Raise it high.
Don't be embarrassed,
it's a good thing.
Raise it high.
You need to understand
in those hands
is where all the money is.
I'm gonna buy the New York Jets
because I'm really
good at knowing
what you say you're not gonna do
and then know you're
gonna actually do it.
Plenty of people in this room,
especially if they're over 45,
said that they would
never get a cell phone.
That their pager
was good enough.
(audience laughing)
A ton of you said you
would never go on Facebook,
eight, ten years ago.
Why?
It was for college kids
and now you live in it.
Right?
We just saw 20, 15% of this room
say they would
never go on Snapchat
and now there's
t-shirts in the crowd
and on phone cases and it
is a part of our world.
Right?
24 minutes ago, it feels like,
definitely two, three days ago,
five days ago for some of
you that watched my vlog.
I said that I was worried about
Instagram's positioning
in the marketplace.
That it was getting
squeezed between Snapchat
and Facebook and then it...
Out of nowhere I wake up
and they make a
product feature change
that competes with Snapchat
and makes it dramatically
more relevant overnight.
This is a moving marketplace.
I am actually
thinking about buying
drive time radio
ads for the first time
in 10 years because the
price has gone down so much
that I'm now
curious if the ROI is there.
I'm not a digitalist
or a futurist.
I don't give a shit
about technology.
I care about your attention
because if
I have your attention,
if I'm good enough
after that point,
I can sell you something.
It's not confusing.
It's not complicated.
The problem is it's hard work.
The difference
between the people
that are gonna win and lose here
is far less about talent.
It's gonna be
built on two very simple
tried and true pillars
that existed long before
the internet came along,
which is the
following two things.
It's 100%.
I could look at
you one by one by one
and map your success based on
two very simple principles.
Number one: your work ethic.
It's just gonna matter.
You know zero successful people
that have built it themselves
that haven't put in the work.
And number two,
the one that almost
everybody in this room
is struggling with
and it's been the absolute
calling card of my career:
patience.
The utter lack of patience
in this room
is the absolute variable of
the people that win and lose.
Especially when we
talk about the things
that I believe in
like these platforms.
The amount of people
that have e-mailed me
and saying, "Hey Gary,
you got me super pumped
"on Snapchat in January.
"Well, I've been
really going at it hard
"and I'm not
getting the results yet,"
and that e-mail
came in fucking February.
(audience laughing)
The amount of time it takes,
let me give you a good example.
I think a lot of you can agree
'cause I know
a lot of you know me,
that I've been
good at this stuff.
That I've been
good at this content
and social media thing
for the last ten years.
The day Facebook pages
came out for people,
the day it came out,
six, seven, eight, nine,
I'm trying to think
about eight years ago?
Until four months ago,
I've been putting
out content everyday.
I've been GaryVee.
I get plenty of exposure,
pounding away
doing everything right,
and from that
day eight years ago
to four months ago,
I amassed
550,000 likes, followers,
on my Facebook fan page.
In the last four months
that page has gone from 550,000
to over a million followers,
organic,
because four months ago,
I figured out how Facebook video
was working in a better way.
All those hours,
my entire livelihood
for seven years,
running the biggest
agency in the space,
and I got to a half a million.
And in four months,
an additional half a million
because chipping
away and learning,
chipping away and learning,
patience, hard work,
(snaps) and a huge game
shift for my business
and my personal brand world.
That is what it takes.
If you have the audacity
to sit here and want to have
a business on your terms,
and crush it and
live your life your way,
then you have to put in the work
into this craft because there is
so much of your consumer's
attention living on it,
it is unbelievable.
It is going to be the only
place to reach consumers.
It's funny.
The reason I brought
up drive time radio
is because again, I'm just
attention arbitraging, right?
I been running
a lot of direct mail.
Who's running direct mail
here for their business?
Raise your hand.
I got to tell you,
if you're running direct mail,
I don't know what you're
spending on your direct mail
versus your Facebook,
but I've been
testing for Wine Library.
very aggressively,
direct mail for
the last two years
because I'm always curious
if my bullshit is real, right?
And then I been
looking at big data
for my big clients
around their couponing
and things of that nature.
I'm sitting here
and telling you today
that Facebook
is far better direct mail
than direct mail itself.
Everything you
want direct mail to do
is done 10 times better
and half the price in
a Facebook environment.
And again, I didn't
close my thought earlier
because I just wanna
get into Q&amp;A.
Are we doing Q&amp;A?
I thought there was some Q&amp;A.
I hope so.
There is? Great, awesome.
The reason I'm worried
about my brands,
Budweiser
and Diageo,
and all these brands
coming into Facebook,
is that five cent word wine
is now $9.
For all of you that are
running Facebook ads
and it costs you
XYZ amount of dollars to
reach a thousand people
and CPM to bring awareness
to your open house
or your organization
or you as an agent,
that is gonna cost you
five to 25 times more
than it's costing you
today in 24 months.
As last year was
the biggest decline
in CPG, consumer packaged goods,
cereals, toothpaste,
all that stuff.
Last year was
the biggest decline
in that industry
of all time
because they spend all
their money on television
and you're not paying
attention anymore.
When those characters figure out
that they need to spend
more money in this world.
It's not like one more agent
in here decides to do it
and they're gonna
spend 5,000 bucks
and it doesn't really become
that much more competitive.
It's that a company goes,
like Macy's.
Macy's went from
a million dollars
to fifty million dollars
spent in Facebook
this last year.
Right?
When you have the other
Fortune 500s do that,
you're gonna be
wiped out of the feed.
You're not gonna
be able to afford
the ads that can drive
your business right now.
And so, I don't want you to sit
with the regret that I have.
You've heard my
story of Wine Library:
three to 60 million.
Let me tell you the great
regret of my career.
That story should
be three to 400 million.
Let me tell you why it's not.
Because when I had Google
AdWords really working for me,
I wasn't smart
enough to go all in.
When it was five cents a click,
I didn't maximize all the
people I could've had.
I was still buying print.
I was still buying radio.
I was still doing
a lot of direct mail.
I was doing local
television commercials.
I was doing event marketing.
I was doing a mix.
What I should've done
and what I'm doing with
Facebook now for my clients
is I'm going pot committed.
When something
is grossly underpriced,
in attention,
you strike.
And that is what we're
living through right now
in a Facebook environment.
And I think you guys
know me well enough.
I'm giving this
advice right now,
not because I love you so much,
but because
DRock is filming this
and I can't wait to
run this in three years
and say, "I fucking told you."
(audience laughing)
And so,
please please please,
if nothing else, if this is
your business and livelihood,
are you telling me that
you don't have five hours
to go home after this conference
and read every article
and watch every video of
how to run great Facebook
ads and make creative?
You don't have that time?
You don't have that
time for your business?
Are you kidding me?
So please, please, please
become disproportionately
educated on
what's going on there.
Number two, figure out
the following thing,
how do you become
a media company?
Because that is the absolute
only way that you can
actually double or
triple your business.
You may not be as extroverted
as me or the next person.
So maybe it's not even video.
Maybe it's the written word.
Maybe it's some other
communication cell.
Maybe it's radio, podcasting.
Podcasting is--
how many people
listening to podcasts?
Raise your hands.
It's real, it's happening.
So you don't need
a national podcast.
Have a local podcast.
Because the funny part is,
it's not about how many
followers you have,
it's about how many followers
you need to buy something.
You don't need a million people
listening to your podcast.
If you have all
37,000 of the town
that you are selling within,
you've won.
You're gonna win.
And so, we are just not
thinking about the opportunities
in the market place in
a significant enough way.
We are living through the single
biggest culture
shift of our time.
Because I promise you
something right now,
for all of you,
that dude back there, respect.
But only four of you are
retiring in 10 years.
What do you think,
somebody that's 22 right now,
is gonna be doing
when they decide
to buy their home in 10 years?
How do you think
they're gonna act?
Where do you think they're gonna
get their information from?
How's it gonna roll?
And by the way,
the punchline is,
it's the same tried and true
shit that's going on now.
It's word of mouth.
It's word of mouth!
So many of you do
business on word of mouth,
but the important
part is that cell phone,
the internet,
that is the infrastructure
of word of mouth
in our society today.
20 years ago, when somebody
did a good job for you,
sold your home,
bought your home,
served you a nice cup of coffee.
Whatever it was, 20 years ago,
when somebody
did something great,
you told one or two of
your girlfriends or homies.
Today, we feel
compelled to share
every one of our fucking
thoughts on social media.
(crowd laughing)
Right?
That is very important
for this room.
And what you need
to be doing tomorrow,
is producing a disproportionate
amount of content
and distributing it everywhere.
Some of them will work,
some of them won't.
But here is the
punchline my friends,
the "wasted time" that I
put into Vine and Socialcam
was the reason that I dominated
on Snapchat and Instagram video.
The things that I learned
on those platforms
mapped to the next thing.
So while you
sit in your seats here
and ponder is it worth
your time, or my favorite:
"Will Snapchat be
around in two years?"
Who gives a shit?
It's around right now.
(crowd laughing)
No advertising company
worried if "Friends" or
"Seinfeld" was gonna be
cancelled in two or three years.
They cared while everybody's
attention was on it.
They ran commercials.
It's not to you to decide
where society should be.
You know what I love
about business people,
agents, marketers, people
that run their businesses?
They feel like their personal
point of view on the world
is how they should be
running their business.
I'm sorry that you're upset that
all our kids are on technology.
I love my modern parents now.
You know, now I have a seven
year old and a four year old.
So I've got a lot of
parent friends, right.
And they love to go out to
dinner with Lizzie
and I and say,
"Oh" and they know what I do.
"Oh this technology
is really shitty.
"It's ruining our kids."
I'm like,
"Rick, that's super cool,
"but the last two times
I hung out with you,
"when little Jake got really
uppity and kind of crazy,
"you threw that
fucking iPad at him
"so fast he couldn't even move."
(audience laughter)
And you guys loved to
go into a restaurant,
walk in and see a couple,
and both of them are on
the phone the whole time,
and you loved to
say to your partner,
"Look how sad that is, right?
"Isn't that so sad?"
When I see that,
I think it's the greatest
thing I've ever seen.
Let me tell you why.
That same couple, 10 years ago,
when they didn't
have their cell phones,
they just sat there in
front of each other
and didn't say a fucking word.
(audience laughter)
Their marriage was fucked.
The phone didn't do it.
(loud audience laughter)
And so I'm just happy for them,
'cause they're
actually doing what
they wanna be doing, right?
(audience laughing)
So, I understand how
you don't want it to be,
but let me remind you this:
your grandmother thought Elvis
shaking his hips was the devil.
(audience laughing)
A lot of us grew up in a world
where they didn't
want us playing Zelda
and Mike Tyson's Punch-Out!!
because we were
gonna get ruined,
yet a lot of our contemporaries,
mainly the kids younger than us,
are making five to
$10 million a year
playing video games.
The world changes
and the biggest part
that I'm worried about
is the world is changing
in a much bigger way
that you
and, or I
realize.
And you need to make a
religious decision here today,
not a tactical one.
This isn't about signing
up for Snapchat
when Gary gets off the stage.
This is about a binary decision
of are you understanding
how important digital is
or are you not?
And more importantly,
making your actions
map
your words.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Do we have time for Q&amp;A
or did I lose my time?
What happened?
- [Man] A couple Gary.
- We got a couple?
Let's do it.
Who's got a question?
Do we have mics
or we goin' ghetto style?
Let's go ghetto style.
Go head,
I'll repeat the question.
(mumbles)
Really good, Michael.
'Preciate it.
- [Michael] Question for you,
I spend a lot of
time on Snapchat--
- Yes.
- [Michael] you're an
inspiration to everybody,
of course.
- Thank you.
- [Michael] and of course,
this whole Instagram Story game.
Yes.
- [Michael] Everyone's coming
up to me and asking me
saying you're spending all
this time on Snapchat,
they're saying
you're spending
all this time, Michael.
You're spending all
this in Snapchat
and now you got Instagram
Stories comin' out.
- You're dead, you're fucked,
it's over.
- [Michael] Yeah, yeah,
all that scary, scary stuff,
right?
I'm excited about
a new opportunity,
but my question to you is
there is obviously only
so much time in a day
and I've always been told
you should also focus.
- Real quick, on that.
- [Michael] So, how do you deal
with those two things?
- Yes, there's only so
much time in a day,
but Sally who's thinking
about buying a home
wants to watch Instagram Stories
and Rick, who
wants to buy a home,
is watching Snapchat stories.
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
How is this complicated?
Have you guys not
just lived through
everybody saying
Facebook was dead
for the last three years
'cause it's not young anymore
and it's the single best
fucking ad product in the world?
My man, the answer is both.
Now,
now, it's important to be smart.
For example,
I believe that Instagram
stories is very powerful
for a lot of people in here
because Snapchat skews
a little bit younger
and everybody's gonna
default into thinking here is
if I'm gonna sell a
$800,000 home,
it's more likely
gonna be a 42-year-old
than a 24-year-old
and I think there's
some validity to that.
So, Instagram Stories
is something
I think every single
person should do here
because I think it
will 100% work
to sell a home today.
Snapchat is something every
single person should do here
because I think it's a platform,
you have to understand,
Snapchat's gonna be an
augmented reality platform.
All the AR companies
they're buying,
the way they do filters,
Snapchat's doing
a lot of other things
and again,
I don't know.
The young and
wealthy on certain,
it depends on your market.
If you're in Kansas
and I love Kansas.
- New York City, Gary.
- What's that?
- [Michael] New York City
with you.
- Yeah, I mean if you're
in New York City,
you have to do Snapchat
because Snapchat
in New York City
is 45 and under.
There's obviously
middle parts of America
and other places
where it skews younger.
You just have to
look at your data,
but the answer is both.
And focus,
stop fucking watching
fucking Netflix and do both.
I love when people are like,
"I've been taught to focus,"
and then I look at their day
and they work six hours a day
(audience laughing)
between their fucking
hour and a half lunch,
them bullshitting in the morning
to talk to everybody,
fucking checking
YouTube 13 times a day
for four minutes each.
I'm like focus?
Fucking work.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering
and applause)
Right?
Both.
Questions?
Yep, yep.
Yeah, take it wherever you want.
- [Dylan] Gary,
thanks for the time.
My name's Dylan Hayle out
of Raleigh, North Carolina.
I'm still hitting doors.
Home to home, I love it.
- You should.
- [Dylan] You're not
gonna get me off it.
Thank you.
- But real quick.
- [Dylan] Sure.
- What's your name again?
- [Dylan] Dylan Hayle.
- Dylan, while you're walking up
to the fucking door,
to knock on it,
you could be
knocking on the door here
and knocking on it.
- [Audience Member]
Facebook Live it.
- [Dylan] Yeah,
that's my question.
How do I incorporate
social media
and modern media marketing
to maximize that?
- I'm being dead serious.
A lot of people know that I,
hold on to it,
that I engage a ton.
I'm busy every minute.
When I get up
from my desk
to go to the bathroom,
I open my phone and engage
with three people on Twitter
or I make a piece of content
that's on my mind, right?
So, literally,
I'm being dead serious.
That wasn't a joke.
When you get out of your car
and you walk
and you go to knock,
in between those two minutes,
in that 39 seconds,
either produce content
or engage with a small community
that you've started building.
- [Dylan] I'm puttin'
out some content there.
Here's me hittin' doors
in this new neighborhood
on a targeting type of thing.
Specifically, how do
I engage that person
that I just made a contact with,
so that they're connected
to me on social media?
- You mean the
person on social me--
- [Dylan] Yeah, the guy I
talked to that says yeah,
I'm thinkin' 'bout
selling my house.
- On the knock ? On door?
- [Dylan] Yep, that guy.
- I would get his
cell phone number.
- [Dylan] Okay, yeah.
- You know what I mean?
I would be like,
"Hey, give me your cell
"and I would text him."
That is the most
intimate relationship
in technology today.
Nobody here is
giving their cell phone out
for text marketing
because it's the one
protective place we have.
If I were you,
I would get as many
of them into the text.
I would take a
picture of their door
and have that as their image,
so you could keep track
and that's what I would do.
- [Dylan] Fair enough.
Thank you.
- You got it.
You're welcome. I got to run.
They're kicking me off,
I'm sorry.
Love you, guys.
Thank you.